12 weeks and protests against a Judicial
Reform Bill show no signs of slowing
down
each week the passes more sections of
Israeli Society adjoining the
demonstrations that want to stop the
knesset's bid to have the ability to
overturn some Supreme Court decisions
but despite this opposition prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu is not
backing down a display of Israeli flags
at the protests is an expression of the
deep sense of patriotism among those
taking part but now even that flag has a
different meaning to different people
one of Israel's most well-known
political columnists Gideon Levy says
political divisions have always existed
Israel never decided what it wants to be
are we a European Western liberal
Society are we
Oriental religious
traditional Society
are we secular or religious are we
Jewish or Muslim or be National I mean
those questions are so open because
Israel had not come into terms with its
identity here in the occupied West Bank
Israeli soldiers stand guard but Israel
faces a crisis here as well Air Force
pilots and reservists are refusing to
report for Duty the numbers are growing
and according to the Israeli military
its ability to continue enforcing the
occupation and ability to launch
airstrikes on Gaza will be severely
impacted
breaking the silence is a group of
former Israeli soldiers that's dedicated
to showing what its members say is the
Grim reality of Israel's occupation of
Palestine the fact that active soldiers
are refusing to serve has come as a
surprise to them to be honest I
use it to serve in the Army became
completely legitimate in our society
when it came to this issue of the
judicial overall I think that it is
brave and it's an important way to
non-violently resist and protest
policies that you are against
and it's not just military personnel
Intelligence Officers are also joining
the protest movement and that's unusual
for people used to working in the
shadows here in Tel Aviv you could be
forgiven for thinking it's business as
usual but the protesters want to
escalate and they are getting numbers
out on the street and their impact is
being felt
it's being felt and the economy as
people take time off to protest
insecurity as soldiers refuse to serve
in the judiciaries the opposition fights
for his independence and in the
government as becoming increasingly more
Hardline as the weeks go on Israel is
now more divided than ever before Imran
Khan Al Jazeera Tel Aviv